Who was the wealthiest person in every century?
That was a question we tried to answer in
a previous TIFO article.
While it was an incredibly difficult question
to get definitive answers to, it did reveal
that the wealthiest private entity in the
19th century was actually not a person – but
a family.
The Rothschild family, descendants of Mayer
A. Rothschild, is still around today and is
believed to be worth over a trillion dollars
combined, thought to be the largest private
fortunate in the history of the world.
Who are the Rothschilds exactly and how did
they amass this tremendous fortune?
Mayer Amschel Rothschild, the patriarch of
the Rothschild fortune, was born in 1744 in
a Jewish ghetto in Frankfurt, Germany.
When his father passed away, Mayer was still
young, but he took over the family’s currency-exchange
business.
The work required Mayer to know a lot about
different kinds of money, currency, and coins
and, soon, he became an expert in rare and
old coins.
To supplement the business, he became a rare
coins dealer.
Now, it just so happened that the Crown Prince
of Hesse (a territory in Germany) was an avid
rare coin collector.
Upon hearing of Mayer’s immense collection,
he approached him and they made several deals.
The deals went so favorably that in a matter
of years, when the Crown Prince became William
IX, Landgrave of Hesse-Kassel (essentially
governor of the region, under the rule of
the Holy Roman Emperor who was Joseph II at
the time), he hired Mayer Rothschild to be
the “Hoffaktor” of his considerable fortune.
A thorough description of the position of
“Hoffaktor” is probably worth a TodayIFoundOut
article by itself, but it essentially translates
to “court Jew.”
While politically incorrect today, it was
quite a favorable, honorable, powerful, and
well-paid position.
Essentially, a Hoffaktor was a Jewish banker
who dealt with the finances, tax-collecting,
and money lending in regards to European royalty;
something close to what a high-priced accountant
would do today.
This began the Rothschilds’ rise to unparalleled
fortune.
Mayer’s international financial influence
continued to rise through the French Revolution
(1789-1799) when he handled virtually all
of the financial aspects of the war.
As put by Count Corti in the book The Rise
of the House of Rothschild, “Every government
wanted money: there were loans to be raised,
exchanges to be negotiated, armies to be clothed
and fed.
Wherever there were business to be done, there
were the Rothschild with their offers and
quotations.”
By 1800, Rothschild was one of the ten wealthiest
men in Frankfurt.
He also had had five sons, each taking up
the family business.
When they got old enough, they were strategically
situated across Europe, bringing their wealth,
expertise, and family connections with them.
This is how many historians have speculated
that the Rothschilds were able to keep their
wealth when so many other prominent families
lost it during these turbulent times in Europe..
With a “judicious selection of points of
vantage,” the Rothschild brothers were stationed
in Frankfurt, London, Naples, Paris, and Vienna,
each “becoming indispensable to his adopted
country,” yet working together with the
family to ensure maximum profit.
Their only true allegiance was to the Rothschild
name.
In 1812, Mayer Rothschild passed away, but
not before assuring the continued fortune
of the family for centuries to come by carefully
arranging marriages for his sons, often to
cousins, keeping everything within the family
to ensure the wealth never left (similar to
royal intermarriages).
(Interestingly, contrary to popular belief,
genetically speaking, cousin marriages aren’t
nearly as bad as is often made out.
See: The Truth About Cousins and Marriage)
The European wars of the early 19th century
furthered the Rothschild’s wealth and influence.
Nathan Mayer Rothschild was the most cunning,
savvy, richest and possibly dishonest of the
famed five Rothschild brothers.
Historians argue the morality behind his methods
– and what are true stories and what were
made up due to jealousy and sometimes antisemitism
– but the result remained the same – he
became exorbitantly rich.
Stationed in London (as part of his father
Mayer’s business plan) when the Napoleonic
Wars officially broke out in 1803, he single-handedly
helped finance the Duke of Wellington and
his opposition to France.
He arranged shipments of bullion (refined,
melted, and rare metals shaped into coins
or bars) to armies across Europe that were
fighting France.
He also used the Rothschild network across
Europe, a system of couriers, agents, information
gatherers (and, as legend had it, carrier
pigeons) who fed him news of the war, at times,
a full day ahead of the government knowing.
This allowed him to spread rumors of losses,
when he knew full well that Britain and her
armies had won.
He could depress stock prices and, when people
panicked, he bought.
The most well-known example of this was pertaining
to the Battle of Waterloo in 1815.
Rumors ran rampant that Britain had lost the
crucial battle, causing markets to crash.
When word came back that it was Napoleon who
had suffered a terrible defeat, it was Nathan
Mayer Rothschild who reaped the enormous benefits
from previously buying stock and bonds at
depressed prices.
This was speculation and insider trading at
its finest, practices that would no doubt
find him in prison today in many nations.
As with many extremely rich industrialists
of the 19th and 20th century (i.e. Rockefeller,
Carnegie, etc.), while their practices may
have not held to the highest of moral standards,
they did use their power and money for good
causes as well.
Nathan Rothschild was known as an abolitionist,
working toward eradicating the slave trade
in Britain.
For instance, it is said he helped finance
the twenty million pounds (about £1.7 billion
today or $2.6 billion) needed to buy out British
plantations, as well as the passing of the
Slavery Abolition Act of 1833.
Through the 19th century, the Rothschild’s
wealth continued to grow.
Nathan had seven children, including four
sons (sons were the ones that carried on the
family business).
His son Lionel became the first Jewish person
to be elected into the House of Commons in
Britain, though, previous to this Jews were
supposed to be barred from it.
In order to get around this, the Prime Minister
John Russell introduced and got passed the
Jewish Relief Act of 1858, taking away this
restriction.
He had a social conscience as well, helping
to finance relief for Irish famine victims.
As the years rolled by and the 19th century
turned into the 20th, the Rothschilds continued
to be among the wealthiest and most influential
bankers in the world.
Nathan Rothschild, better known as Lord Rothschild,
began issuing loans to countries beyond Europe,
most notably the US.
Beyond banking, the Rothschilds are also well
known in the world of wine and art collecting.
In the late 19th century, the Lord Rothschild
arranged for the purchase of several estates
in France.
They became world-renown vineyards and, to
this day, Rothschild wine is among the most
expensive in the world.
As for art collecting, the Lord Rothschild
and his brother, Albert, were avid collectors
and buyers of works of art, filling their
enormous homes with priceless paintings, provocative
sculptures, French furniture, china, and scientific
equipment.
Said the Baroness Bettina der Rothschild to
the New York Times in 1999 about her great
uncle the Lord Rothschild, “It was Nathaniel
who especially loved buying scientific instruments.
Who could ever think that microscopes were
beautiful, but these were.”
These collections were hailed across Europe
and the envy of many.
However, in March of 1938, within 24 hours
of Hitler’s SS Army “annexing” Austria,
Nazis stripped the Rothschild’s homes in
the region of all their priceless possessions.
With the intention of putting the collection
on display in his own proposed Hitler Museum
in Linz, Austria (Hitler’s hometown), Hitler
had all the art hidden away in a ski resort
high in the Alps.
The massive collection was finally discovered
by American GIs after the war.
It took 54 years (1999) before the Austrian
government decided to give the art back to
their rightful owners, the descendants of
the Rothschild family.
Many of these works were hanging in Austrian
museums prior to this, despite the knowledge
that they had been stolen during the war.
However, months after receiving most of the
art back, the Rothschild family decided to
donate or sell nearly all of the collection.
Said Baroness Bettina der Rothschild at the
time, “But it just doesn’t make sense
to keep them.
We all live very differently today than my
parents did.
Not only are the security questions terrifying
and the insurance costs prohibitive, but this
type of 18th-century French furniture needs
a butler and two housemaids constantly polishing
it.
That’s just not the way we live.”
They’ve also in the last century or so donated
several amazing estates, such as the Waddesdon
Manor and the Schloss Hinterleiten.
Who was the wealthiest person in every century?
That was a question we tried to answer in
a previous TIFO article.
While it was an incredibly difficult question
to get definitive answers to, it did reveal
that the wealthiest private entity in the
19th century was actually not a person – but
a family.
The Rothschild family, descendants of Mayer
A. Rothschild, is still around today and is
believed to be worth over a trillion dollars
combined, thought to be the largest private
fortunate in the history of the world.
Who are the Rothschilds exactly and how did
they amass this tremendous fortune?
Mayer Amschel Rothschild, the patriarch of
the Rothschild fortune, was born in 1744 in
a Jewish ghetto in Frankfurt, Germany.
When his father passed away, Mayer was still
young, but he took over the family’s currency-exchange
business.
The work required Mayer to know a lot about
different kinds of money, currency, and coins
and, soon, he became an expert in rare and
old coins.
To supplement the business, he became a rare
coins dealer.
Now, it just so happened that the Crown Prince
of Hesse (a territory in Germany) was an avid
rare coin collector.
Upon hearing of Mayer’s immense collection,
he approached him and they made several deals.
The deals went so favorably that in a matter
of years, when the Crown Prince became William
IX, Landgrave of Hesse-Kassel (essentially
governor of the region, under the rule of
the Holy Roman Emperor who was Joseph II at
the time), he hired Mayer Rothschild to be
the “Hoffaktor” of his considerable fortune.
A thorough description of the position of
“Hoffaktor” is probably worth a TodayIFoundOut
article by itself, but it essentially translates
to “court Jew.”
While politically incorrect today, it was
quite a favorable, honorable, powerful, and
well-paid position.
Essentially, a Hoffaktor was a Jewish banker
who dealt with the finances, tax-collecting,
and money lending in regards to European royalty;
something close to what a high-priced accountant
would do today.
This began the Rothschilds’ rise to unparalleled
fortune.
Mayer’s international financial influence
continued to rise through the French Revolution
(1789-1799) when he handled virtually all
of the financial aspects of the war.
As put by Count Corti in the book The Rise
of the House of Rothschild, “Every government
wanted money: there were loans to be raised,
exchanges to be negotiated, armies to be clothed
and fed.
Wherever there were business to be done, there
were the Rothschild with their offers and
quotations.”
By 1800, Rothschild was one of the ten wealthiest
men in Frankfurt.
He also had had five sons, each taking up
the family business.
When they got old enough, they were strategically
situated across Europe, bringing their wealth,
expertise, and family connections with them.
This is how many historians have speculated
that the Rothschilds were able to keep their
wealth when so many other prominent families
lost it during these turbulent times in Europe..
With a “judicious selection of points of
vantage,” the Rothschild brothers were stationed
in Frankfurt, London, Naples, Paris, and Vienna,
each “becoming indispensable to his adopted
country,” yet working together with the
family to ensure maximum profit.
Their only true allegiance was to the Rothschild
name.
In 1812, Mayer Rothschild passed away, but
not before assuring the continued fortune
of the family for centuries to come by carefully
arranging marriages for his sons, often to
cousins, keeping everything within the family
to ensure the wealth never left (similar to
royal intermarriages).
(Interestingly, contrary to popular belief,
genetically speaking, cousin marriages aren’t
nearly as bad as is often made out.
See: The Truth About Cousins and Marriage)
The European wars of the early 19th century
furthered the Rothschild’s wealth and influence.
Nathan Mayer Rothschild was the most cunning,
savvy, richest and possibly dishonest of the
famed five Rothschild brothers.
Historians argue the morality behind his methods
– and what are true stories and what were
made up due to jealousy and sometimes antisemitism
– but the result remained the same – he
became exorbitantly rich.
Stationed in London (as part of his father
Mayer’s business plan) when the Napoleonic
Wars officially broke out in 1803, he single-handedly
helped finance the Duke of Wellington and
his opposition to France.
He arranged shipments of bullion (refined,
melted, and rare metals shaped into coins
or bars) to armies across Europe that were
fighting France.
He also used the Rothschild network across
Europe, a system of couriers, agents, information
gatherers (and, as legend had it, carrier
pigeons) who fed him news of the war, at times,
a full day ahead of the government knowing.
This allowed him to spread rumors of losses,
when he knew full well that Britain and her
armies had won.
He could depress stock prices and, when people
panicked, he bought.
The most well-known example of this was pertaining
to the Battle of Waterloo in 1815.
Rumors ran rampant that Britain had lost the
crucial battle, causing markets to crash.
When word came back that it was Napoleon who
had suffered a terrible defeat, it was Nathan
Mayer Rothschild who reaped the enormous benefits
from previously buying stock and bonds at
depressed prices.
This was speculation and insider trading at
its finest, practices that would no doubt
find him in prison today in many nations.
As with many extremely rich industrialists
of the 19th and 20th century (i.e. Rockefeller,
Carnegie, etc.), while their practices may
have not held to the highest of moral standards,
they did use their power and money for good
causes as well.
Nathan Rothschild was known as an abolitionist,
working toward eradicating the slave trade
in Britain.
For instance, it is said he helped finance
the twenty million pounds (about £1.7 billion
today or $2.6 billion) needed to buy out British
plantations, as well as the passing of the
Slavery Abolition Act of 1833.
Through the 19th century, the Rothschild’s
wealth continued to grow.
Nathan had seven children, including four
sons (sons were the ones that carried on the
family business).
His son Lionel became the first Jewish person
to be elected into the House of Commons in
Britain, though, previous to this Jews were
supposed to be barred from it.
In order to get around this, the Prime Minister
John Russell introduced and got passed the
Jewish Relief Act of 1858, taking away this
restriction.
He had a social conscience as well, helping
to finance relief for Irish famine victims.
As the years rolled by and the 19th century
turned into the 20th, the Rothschilds continued
to be among the wealthiest and most influential
bankers in the world.
Nathan Rothschild, better known as Lord Rothschild,
began issuing loans to countries beyond Europe,
most notably the US.
Beyond banking, the Rothschilds are also well
known in the world of wine and art collecting.
In the late 19th century, the Lord Rothschild
arranged for the purchase of several estates
in France.
They became world-renown vineyards and, to
this day, Rothschild wine is among the most
expensive in the world.
As for art collecting, the Lord Rothschild
and his brother, Albert, were avid collectors
and buyers of works of art, filling their
enormous homes with priceless paintings, provocative
sculptures, French furniture, china, and scientific
equipment.
Said the Baroness Bettina der Rothschild to
the New York Times in 1999 about her great
uncle the Lord Rothschild, “It was Nathaniel
who especially loved buying scientific instruments.
Who could ever think that microscopes were
beautiful, but these were.”
These collections were hailed across Europe
and the envy of many.
However, in March of 1938, within 24 hours
of Hitler’s SS Army “annexing” Austria,
Nazis stripped the Rothschild’s homes in
the region of all their priceless possessions.
With the intention of putting the collection
on display in his own proposed Hitler Museum
in Linz, Austria (Hitler’s hometown), Hitler
had all the art hidden away in a ski resort
high in the Alps.
The massive collection was finally discovered
by American GIs after the war.
It took 54 years (1999) before the Austrian
government decided to give the art back to
their rightful owners, the descendants of
the Rothschild family.
Many of these works were hanging in Austrian
museums prior to this, despite the knowledge
that they had been stolen during the war.
However, months after receiving most of the
art back, the Rothschild family decided to
donate or sell nearly all of the collection.
Said Baroness Bettina der Rothschild at the
time, “But it just doesn’t make sense
to keep them.
We all live very differently today than my
parents did.
Not only are the security questions terrifying
and the insurance costs prohibitive, but this
type of 18th-century French furniture needs
a butler and two housemaids constantly polishing
it.
That’s just not the way we live.”
They’ve also in the last century or so donated
several amazing estates, such as the Waddesdon
Manor and the Schloss Hinterleiten.
Today, the Rothschild family still exists
and is still ridiculously rich (as mentioned
with a combined wealth estimated at over a
trillion dollars), though in recent times
tend on the whole to try to keep themselves
very low-profile, even with donations to charities.
They also no longer focus as much on banking,
instead often focusing their energies on wine,
asset management, charity work, real estate,
and social activism, attempting to keep with
the family motto- Concordia Integritas Industria
(“Unity, Integrity, Entrepreneurship”).